interesting hey bet
welcome I'm trying to think
probably Port the rest of the code in
here the rest of the
losses probably ideal
be okay so episode length is supposed to
go up
and then return starts very
low and okay it's supposed to go up so
we logging
returns so let's do um
let's figure out the extra weird reward
that they added and then we'll go from
is this it yeah hold on this
is this is it okay
okay I'm pretty sure the only thing that
we really need to do
yeah it's got to be here right update
mini
Ops you get the amp
Ops then you do self. model
forward
on no this is the rapper
the only thing worse than debugging very
convoluted
code particularly when it's not your own
very convoluted
code is doing so half
asleep need to catch up on some rest
am
Builder Network and return
net wait then what the hell right
it batch
dick take a dictionary doesn't
it eval actor eval
critic Mo and
sigma how the hell does this thing give
you a
they come up with some really freaking
crazy losses
replay they can cat these
together just demo
logic okay so this doesn't look very
bad yeah this doesn't look very bad so
all I have to do here it's just an extra
OBS am OBS replay and am OBS demo to be
recorded
so I need to get these
into into here and then I can compute
the loss and then we should be
count oh so that's they're doing some
bizarre thing here with
replay yeah we shouldn't care about this
we just
actually neither of these freaking Mak
sense do
I see so one of these is just your data
formatted the way that it is expected
and the other one is from the demo
okay so
in order to push a
PR do I need gpg keys or can I you can
just well you don't push a PR you submit
a PR and then I approve it but
yeah I don't know why you would need
anything else
who is this as well on
Twitch is this someone I know from uh
Discord or
elsewhere oh um yeah they like their
processes we hate processes we like
simple things
you know there are a lot of things that
um smaller Dev groups and small
companies just do because big companies
do them doesn't mean that you should do
them because of that
so
weird this
is so they
wrong but I'm not positive hang
on how do they do this
[Music]
in I'm not sure what you're pring as
well but it's uh
generally a good idea to well if it's a
simple fix then you're letting me know
here is fine but for bigger stuff we
manage a lot of Dev on our
Discord and there are a lot of helpful
people in there as
well it's about emulation High
okay that's um probably the most
complicated file in the proc
project
specifically headings to M single
M should be
[Music]
changed let me
see for
bug do I have it as a dictionary I think
you're right I think I do have it as a
dictionary
wait this doesn't return the dictionary
though this
is no wait when you call observation
space and pettings who is a function
right you pass it an
agent and
um self M
observations oh wait hold on
so
m i see because it's the
internal should it be single observation
space no that that doesn't exist in
petting
on yeah I'm just I'm being careful here
because of if I just YOLO merge a thing
here this is like uh this gets used by
not any of our ocean environments but
this gets used by every single third
party
environment so and up yes okay M signal
I see
yes that looks reasonable single
observation space m
single yep okay that is fair uh I'm in
the middle of uh commit on this at the
moment if you PR it I'll merge it or I
can just add it thank you for that that
seems to be correct to
me
yeah good catch
thank you yeah this petting zo wrapper
is kind of a pain um we need it because
you know compatibility with existing
petting zoo M but the
dictionary the dictionary interface of
petting zoo really kills your
performance on
everything so like all of our our new
environments they use uh we have our own
API that's basically the gym Vector API
for our new ocean
environments and um yeah that ends up
being way way
faster we also tend to bypass the whole
observation space thing again because of
the speed though that's not strictly
necessary um
yeah but we do have this for existing
multi- agent TS
whatsoever but fine this is how it's
supposed to
what got you hooked to coding as an
undergrad I was already coding for a
long time before then I've been coding
since I I don't know 13 or 14 or
something and frankly I don't know
because um
it's much better writing code now than
when I started I guess there's like a
wow I can just build stuff thing even
though even if you quite don't quite
know how to do it when you uh are pretty
new but
um yeah I don't know
like programming is pretty much the only
place in the world where you can just
pull out your laptop and just build
whatever the hell without Capital
requirements or teams or management you
can just do whatever pretty much
[Music]
um probably
like junior year of undergrad I did uh I
did some stuff in vision and natural
language processing
be and that's such a
weird weird thing isn't
it way this is but we'll like let me do
this for a
bit let me try this so can I
do something like this
n um I mean I've
been I started neural MMO like my
sophomore year of undergrad it's a
project that I've been working on in
some capacity
I've been working on in some capacity
for like the last8 years at this
point I mean I have my whole thesis on
neural MMO and why it's important to do
stuff like that
okay so this does give
you this gives you demos
isn't there supposed to be a time
component like what
streaming till
probably
dinner I'm just I'm kind of confused at
the moment because I'm working on
something where like there's not it's
very difficult to make forward progress
here because the code just doesn't make
any bloody
me I mean this seems very wrong the way
it
is hang on
something yeah it'll be more fun when
I'm working on stuff where I can make
progress quickly and have cool results
um this thing is
like good programmers solve really
important problems bad programmers make
very hard problems for good programmers
to them
it still doesn't explain the way that
they're doing
um their
weird I mean they're clearly not
sampling sequences unless
I'm totally missing
what's the best reference to make
multi-agent probably
simple you know what let me check in
here
like if there were a license for
programming this could base would be
caused for losing
it thankfully there
isn't but like holy hell how do you even
write this
mess and this is after Kung has cleaned
it up substantially
well maybe they're using it in a way
that I don't understand
okay so there's M OBS this is just like
the OBS in the format that you're going
to need
demo okay hang on maybe there's
something here
oh I think they're doing a difference
between the
it looks like they're not sampling
trajectories it looks like they're just
sampling
so I think they're only giving you the
the goal
State the final state of the motion is
that
now hold on I think I think it makes
sense I think it might make
so if these are the goal
States so we sample a bunch of gold
States
I'd have to see how they're used in the
trainer I think
right yeah I think I have to see how
they're used in the
doing they're using po but it doesn't
seem like they understand what PO
is I mean this is like a weird hybrid
thing this doesn't even make any bloody
sense for
man I don't want to just sit here for
the next hour and stare at
this I think I understand what is being
done but I don't understand how the hell
the code does that cuz the code is dog
you know I just legitimately don't know
what the hell to do with this um this is
just such a
think okay the only thing that I can
think to do
that would
work okay I have to do it in the end
player is the only way I can think to do
this I don't even know if I'm right but
this is literally the only thing I can
think of
so there's got to be a limitation how
bad freaking code can be that you have
to deal with
like I mean some way this is worse than
useless cuz there's a reference that
exists to be matched but it's like this
may as well be just an obfuscated binary
with how shitty it is
observation hang
on eval
simple I mean this is just obnoxious but
um
yeah K it's going in the main clean puff
rall I'm going to Branch this this will
be a branch there's no other good way to
do
this at least as far as I can see
there's no other good way to do this
yeah it'll be custom clean puffer it's
not that many changes we just have to
add two things to this experience
buffer
um I looked at the code for the longest
time I still can't figure out what
they're doing with amp OBS because it
doesn't seem like they're training on
sequences correctly I can't tell um
their batching code sucks so I think I
know how to do it as long as we have
good data coming out at the end
data so now all I have to do is Port
over this
loss let me see this loss
I also don't know what this other loss
is this bound loss or
whatever I couldn't figure that
out but if I
[Music]
find where is this stupid
thing skip bound loss I think so as well
demo I looking at the wrong file
[Music]
go so then this gives you and I don't
know what the hell is this I don't know
what this replay is I have no idea what
this fet
is um but
know oh wait cuz this is the
discriminator is there no imitation law
I think this Ford is very different
right yeah so
here I don't know what this is
for but you
do they have three different op here and
I don't understand why they have three
it seems like they should only have two
it is the format of the observation of
what your current state is and then the
same thing for the demo so I don't know
what the hell this is because I don't
know what this piece is here um oh I'm
covered by camera yeah I don't know what
this piece is here so I don't know what
this piece
is
um but this we can do because this is
just eval disc EV this you call the
model on both and
losss how do you have this big of a loss
what's wrong with
it's negative 1: one cuz it looks like
they're trying to bound it
to zero and one here
but uh I think I can implement this
maybe I I don't know man they're doing
weird
morph I want to make sure we're like
actually building the right thing and
not just building stupid things cuz
they're like in the
there's regularization and penalty and
stuff to do as well but that's the base
whatever isn't there a reward term that
you add as well from
this or is it just a
there's a reward modification from this
right
okay so everybody's just using each
other's garbage code great
um let's see what this
does I'll probably have to make yeah amp
OBS buff I'll have to do what
just going to push this stuff to Isaac
Jim in a bit
uh the nice thing is this doesn't use
fetch at all in
the clean puff roll
data is this temporal data here that I'm
looking at what's up with
that wait that doesn't even make sense
because how can it be 10 steps a ob
should come from the current state of
the
simulator how could you possibly have 10
steps right this is literally based on
your current state
then am demo is none which is just
lovely
right wait how the hell is it even
possible it's only 10 they're literally
only doing 10
step in like a continuous time problem
they're doing 10 step segment
like what that doesn't make any
this I can just let them do their stupid
thing right and I can just
do for now
I can just set this to
curve and OBS
buff that's a
quite okay well actually we'll put this
in here
okay so on reset you reset this buffer
and then you do self do am or demo
idx is zero
do plus equal
one and then we do
per am demo
buff is going to be equal
to
am
demo demo bu
one
zero set this to
buff and then what we should be able to
do off of
this is instead of getting this thing
that makes no sense which is getting all
at once these
trajectories we'll get these that will
actually line up
presumably the M's can reset at
different times
though or do we just not like I don't
know how this interacts with
loss
[Music]
function I don't know if that is
the the loss that you're showing me is
actually the loss that they
have does this reduce to Binary cross
entropy somehow don't think it does
wait are they resetting individual
environments every 10 steps or more
frequently to handle this crazy demo
thing
don't now got
you
uh the only thing is that they this gets
called on reset
now so whenever you reset you need to
pick new ones of these well actually
this should just be
nids and then this should just be
I guess s the
all I hate that they do this actually it
should be length of
so all in by like
this slice
none that should be a little
faster
and this really doesn't need to be
allocated here either
there's really no reason for it to be
allocated at that St that
garbage there we go it's a little
better and then we can avoid this
confusing thing here where it seems like
these are
Dynamic this can go here
okay yeah K so explain to me how this is
supposed to work then if I have this
wrong because I don't think it works any
other way than what I'm currently doing
it so what they're doing right is
they're calling fetch to get a batch of
data all at once uh inside of train
right and then that gives you your demos
until you're finished with this batch of
demos uh and then they have some really
weird experience buffer that makes it
really difficult to track how they're
actually matching up time steps uh for
the samples to their buffer and I
actually have no idea if they're
handling resets across environments at
all I don't think that they are because
I don't see how Dynamic M time matches
up to this so what I'm doing instead is
I'm just making it part of the
environment and it will just generate
new demos for each environment whenever
it resets that's all I was doing with
it cuz something doesn't match up here
right
look I still don't see how that's
relevant though like whatever loss they
using you need to make sure that you're
actually taking uh contiguous segments
right so I don't know how you control
trajectory bounds
otherwise it seems way cleaner to me to
just ample it in the
end because I honestly can't follow what
they're doing with their data
style isn't there a reward function as
well though
the demo uses the same format right it's
the
demo and regardless I think you still
need to
match trajectories
up it's actually Motion Plus matching
right but like if if I don't do
this right so if I don't actually make
sure that the because I don't know how
to match up the observation uh the amp
observations to the actual trajectories
without taking doing it in the
environment right because all these are
going to go into a big experien buffer
and the experienced buffer like you know
puts everything together flat and
they're not going to have the same
trajectory length or anything so once
they're in there I have no idea how we
match up
maps I also don't understand how the
curve that you sent me you have episode
length increasing to like 80 or
something if the animations are like uh
if it's only length 10 for the source
data
ocean matching
reward how can it be if you're sampling
new
data in
training are they loading the same data
twice or something
isn't the target Motion in the amp
format I'm happy to jump on a PA if it's
easier
ridiculous motions to be trained
resampled every 500 epoch
what the
heck signed well that's what I'm doing
here with the
ones is it not the
that current and previous one frame but
then there's also a demo isn't there
demo I guess the demo is the target is
that the
case so is it not your two previous
frames demo is fake samples produced by
the
agent that doesn't seem like is
agent right this comes from motion Li
doesn't
it this looks to me like it's
loading like imitation
replays or something
yeah
so look the loss
here so you have discriminator
loss and the discriminator loss is the
sum of two components one of which comes
from
well they concatenate this replay logic
which I don't know what this is maybe
this is the previous
frame fake sample but it's concatenated
with the real
sample the loss here is just agent logic
demo
logic and then this thing so I
implemented this portion here
the only thing I don't have is I don't
have the replay logic because I don't
know what it
is like I don't know what a fake the
fake sample
sample is that what it is the pre
previous
sample cuz I can get a buffer with the
sample but that doesn't seem right to me
either because the
what's the discriminator doing isn't it
just trying to figure
out see the loss function that you sent
me on that is not what is implemented so
I'm confused
the discriminator is just trying to tell
apart your current state from the demo
State isn't it or is it doing more than
that
value but they have the demo in
here so in the code base for this paper
they have the demo in
here so I don't know if by real and fake
they mean demo and then whatever the
hell they noid doing at the moment
see you're saying it's this but I'm
looking at the code and this is not what
I'm seeing
oh look this is
and you have it right here the
discriminator loss negative plus
positive here it is right here right oh
wait and then they Square it hold
on no but this is different this is for
the logits they're squaring logit no the
actual loss is right here this is binary
cross
entropy so it's the sum of two binary
cross entropy terms is what they're
using for this discriminator
I mean either way I apparently need the
previous step so I'll go get the
previous step I
guess I can do
that for
it's going to be more complicated than
this isn't it [ __ ]
obnoxious I think I can get it it's just
it's going to be
I'm going to have to change this a
little bit because the buffer at the
moment I won't be sampling it
correctly
um yeah but the idea would just be to
get the
to just have the environment make the
current and previous observations
available at every step so we can just
stick those into our buffer and then we
should be able to do stuff with that
do I need this like difference anywhere
else K because technically I could just
hack it and I could have
um if I mask by the duns I think I can
just like shift The Experience buffer by
one and do it that
way but I suspect we probably need this
in other places or
no how many freaking Lo loses do they
have well also why are we even looking
at these papers what's more
here here's the binary cross
entropy presume a blade
OBS wait this doesn't even use the
freaking demo does
this
no State
hats this is the new discriminator it's
already implemented
the main thing I'm worried about here is
not having we need this data here we
need this data
set
um where did the demos even comeing at
all
simulate
pose I guess input pose is going to be
the
test data use as a subset is the format
same
yeah simulated pose X hat okay so then
the
input motion refers to the demo data
the input motion refers to the demo data so that's
so that's
here so this is this first
loss and then you have
P okay so you have this loss so this is
done in the environment
right but what I don't understand is it
looks like you're loading data twice for
some
reason motion
discriminator okay so this is not right
here this is
not sampled input State and simulated
pose
okay so I don't see any difference
between current and previous state
um I don't see any difference between
current and previous state at all in
here do
you this is what I mean with like making
sure we're doing the the actual correct
one because otherwise we're wasting our
time so let's not waste our time on
that um because here's the thing right
we are already loading the data in the
environment without having to call this
stupid task function whatever from the
trainer we're already loading the data
in the environment in order to compute
the state right because the state here
we have the uh the
difference between the demo and the
simulated state right so we'll just put
the demo State into the uh experience
buffer as I was starting to do already
except we're to have it even easier than
that because instead of having to hack
the task sampler we'll hack the one
that's actually already integrated and
timed
correctly with the other one right there
should be a different load
hold on we don't even have multiple
different states
man yeah we don't even have multiple
different states so we're just totally
spinning our Wheels here like getting
confused with all these stupid
complicated previous workpapers when the
thing that we actually care about is not
that complicated look at
this
right this is the
state yeah the data format to get this
is a little bit annoying but like we
have this buried in the code somewhere
already because this is just joint
position joint velocity angular velocity
right so we have
this this is just component wise loss
over that right with different
weightings this is computable from this
as well just from these four terms as
this reward
term Sim this is yeah simulated post the
hat is simulated post Tilda is uh is
imitation
data this is also done only on the
state imitation is implemented in
compute
reward okay so I the motion lip cash is
then the thing to understand
here I think I have the clarity back of
what we need to do CU we're you know the
morth paper is not that bad honestly
it's the [ __ ] reference papers that
are just dog [ __ ] so complicated and
their code sucks
um yeah this doesn't involve any
difference of States this doesn't
involve anything that requires us to
resample motions from the
trainer
right but the discriminator doesn't
involve a difference of States
look this here the Tilda is the
imitation data right and then this one
here is just your reference
state so this here this thing you have
this for your simulated data and you
have this from the data
set and then this you take the
difference here there's never a
difference of like state to next state
it's only imitated data to simulated
data so the thing from the previous
paper is just not relevant
because they replaced the motion
discriminator here right solely on
physics simulator they yeah
okay so this we can do cuz we're almost
there as
this I have this lost in clean
puffer you say that we have the rewards
right do we have this one as well no we
don't have this one yet but this one
gets added in
um this one has to get added
in where's r
e r m r e
okay so RM and re e come from the
environment so these two are both in the
environment right which you said that we
have imitation and energy yes perfect so
this one so there two pieces left right
there're just two pieces left um and
they're not that bad because all we need
to do is we get
hat well we get both of them right one
of these is observation and the other
one is the um uh reference observation
from the imitation data and then this
has to go
right okay I think we've gotten progress
here because I think I am clear on what
to do
now okay so the only thing that's
slightly annoying right is I have to do
it here before we compute
J but that's not bad I'll just compute
it for the full back
right
here maybe I have to move j down maybe I
have to like recompute je or
something I think we have to recompute J
in in the loop now is the only thing but
we have the sconed version so we're fine
um so this this je computation will be
moved down into the loop here we'll put
it like here
is and the
discriminator uh reward will go there
and then we'll compute the discriminator
loss and we should be done and then the
only thing we got to worry about is the
data difference
all right I'm going to go grab dinner um
I'll be back in a bit and I'm going to
try to get this implemented for you
tonight k um if you can figure out just
so we're clear on the data and we have
the data loaded in the correct format
then I think we'll be good and we'll
have like the whole rest of the time to
run experiments and to get the result to
match so I'm going to go get some food
um let me just check restream in case
anybody's been watching this there are a
couple people watching me talk to my
side monitor which is amusing so for
those folks uh we normally do much more
interesting RL around here we do ultra
high performance on a variety of
different environments
you can play with some of them right
here on the
website um if you're interested in
supporting this work free check out the
GitHub check out the code star the
repository that really helps us out and
other than that you can join the Discord
or follow me on X for more thank you
very much and I will likely be back for
an hour or two after dinner to